hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to talk about how the martial arts
is about a whole lot more than just
fighting
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so this is the third in my
three-part series on 20 years of
sparring with aikido and what i learned
from it so in the first video i talked
mostly about uh when i learned aikido
and after i became a black belt in
aikido aikido didn't work for me in a
fight so then i went to mixed martial
arts and brazilian jiu jitsu to figure
out how it worked in a fight that just
confirmed for me that in fact aikido
didn't work in a fight
then i ended up having to enter a dog
brothers meeting of the pack and in that
dog brothers meeting the pack some of my
aikido techniques actually came out for
the first time that i'd been trying all
this stuff in a bunch of serious
fighting and that really made me curious
about what aikido is doing how come it
worked now all of a sudden that
encouraged me to open a small school in
my hometown where i got a small group of
guys and we pounded each other against
the walls repeatedly until we figured
out what aikido was about and then this
part of the series is talking about my
continuation from there
so at this point i kind of thought
aikido was a mobile weapon platform and
that's a really weird name and i still
don't know a better thing to call it but
aikido is kind of unlike a lot of other
martial arts in my opinion in the fact
that the idea of aikido is mostly just
to keep you free right so being able to
move around free and if you can move
around free then you could stack a
weapon platform on top of that to
increase your odds of doing well in
conflict so meaning you know someone
wants to get me my idea is just to stay
aloof so they can't get me i want to
stay free and then if the engagement's
really serious i could use a weapon on
top of that so i could use a weapon to
keep myself free now this mobile weapon
platform idea while it sounds good for a
survival situation it doesn't sound much
like the art of peace which is what
aikido is supposed to be it's supposed
to be this art of peace so how does
mobile weapon platform and art of peace
how do they jive together
at this time when i kind of figured this
out so probably around 2010 that this
idea the mobile weapon platform started
to cement for me
i didn't really care i just liked that
the aikido techniques had functionality
and i could see them coming off
regularly and i thought that was really
cool and all the technical stuff i
learned in aikido worked out for me and
so ikea there's a mobile weapon platform
and not an art of peace at that time i
didn't really care and and to tell you
the truth at that time i really wasn't
that interested in an art of peace
anyway so that's cool to me you know
it's a mobile weapon platform
so
now knowing it's a mobile weapon
platform and knowing that the heart of
my aikido is training me to stay mobile
while i use a weapon i wanted to get
better at using weapons so i started
studying weapon specific martial arts i
went and say kendo for a while i studied
hima competing in longsword and dusak i
studied sword buckler if i even became a
certified
pistol and concealed carry weapons
instructor for firearms because i wanted
to understand what the whole world of
weapons was about now this made a lot of
sense for me if i was thinking not of
like wanting to go beat people up but
simply if anyone wanted to give me
trouble i could stay mobile and use my
weapon long enough to be successful
right so so that answered all of my
self-defense needs
not long after i had got this this is
about 2011 the opportunity to take over
aikido fresno which the school i started
sitting aikido in
it became available so the head
instructor was ready to leave and a new
head instructor needed to come into
aikido fresno and i had my opportunity
and i took it so now i've gone from
teaching a small group of ruffians in a
garage where we were smashing each other
around all the time to having to teach
in a public school that had children and
older people and all walks of life so my
eye kiddo kind of had to change because
the answers that i had developed in that
garage were going to be different than
the answers i was going to give these
people so you know older people
they weren't as athletic as any of the
guys i had been training with in the
garage i had a bunch of guys i was
training with in the garage they were
all athletic and they didn't mind
getting pounded around all the time and
were physically robust and they could do
that these older people couldn't handle
that kind of training so my training
kind of had to adapt for them and i th
the mobile weapon platform wasn't really
too bad for the older people because
it's like well you know if you get a
weapon and you understand how to use the
weapon as long as you can stay mobile
and will make you as mobile as you can
be um you could use that weapon and you
could defend yourself but that was a bad
answer for the children in the school
because we're not going to arm the
children no matter what it's kind of a
crazy idea to arm kids
now we could make the argument that when
those kids get older they can use the
mobile weapon platform but right now
could i teach a 10 year old right now
how to defend himself
now i know that there's lots of videos
where they show you know a 10 year old
doing a kodage to an adult and then
flying through the air that's not
realistic so if an adult really wanted
to attack a 10 year old the 10 year old
is not going to code to guys the adult
in a way that's going to stop them from
doing harm to the kid so how do we teach
a kid to defend themselves i realized
that a lot of my answers were just be
stronger become stronger that's how you
do it right so that's how i do it i'm
stronger i can handle more and that's
better but are there answers inside of
aikido that help the kids so i started
to emphasize different things i started
to emphasize
awareness and attention to details right
so by being aware and attentive to
details these kids could see when a
dangerous situation was unfolding and
get out of there before the situation
became too dire right so even a
five-year-old could do that or a
five-year-old's never gonna kodogai sure
shionage an adult they could see a
dangerous situation and get to their
parents or get to safety and if we talk
to them about what that is they're able
to do that this also helps for older
people or smaller people or physically
not as dominant people because now
they're not thinking oh if there's a
fight i'm gonna get in there and solve
it they're thinking that's a bad
situation what can i do to defend myself
the best or take care of others around
me right so a lot of times when you talk
about get taking care of others around
you you think of like oh i need to get
in there and fight someone off well
maybe you just need to take the others
with you and get out of the situation is
what you need to do so
by being attentive to situations before
they become fights you actually do
better in the situation
and then it slowly dawned on me aikido
supposed to be a martial art that's not
about fighting
so why had i been spending so much time
making aikido
about fighting
it's because i wanted to fight i wanted
to become better at fighting now through
the course of all the study i did become
a lot better at fighting i became better
at fighting by going and doing martial
arts where they fought all the time
right i went and did mixed martial arts
i went and did brazilian jiu jitsu i
competed in tournaments i fought with
weapons i trained weapon systems so i
learned about fighting
but it wasn't through the aikido the
aikido was actually trying to teach me
something else
so it's said that morehe yoshi the
founder of aikido offered a teaching
certificate to any one of his students
who could sneak up and surprise him
now that would be a really weird thing
to do if aikido was about applying
kodagaisha's and nikyos and koshinages
and the things that i had been trying to
get aikido to do for a long time because
someone who can surprise him can't
necessarily do any of those so why would
he give a teaching certificate to
someone who could surprise him
i think it's because the martial art of
aikido is about being attentive and
aware and making accords with the thing
around you so for example if you could
take this old guy who was real dodgy and
careful and and paying attention all the
time and you could sneak up on him you
were clearly capable of making accords
with the world around you because you
wouldn't disturb anything around you so
you could sneak up on this old guy so
you would be highly capable of paying
attention to what's going on around you
and making accords with it and that's
what aikido is about aikido is about
making harmonies
making harmonies helps us survive really
dangerous situations and not by trying
to dominate them but by trying to fit in
with them so this is what i started to
realize aikido was about and the more i
tried to teach towards my older students
and my younger students the more i
realized that aikido was about being
ahead of the fight and not being in the
fight while aikido has a set of skills
that deals with struggling and trying to
get out of that situation that's not the
real emphasis of aikido now that might
be the emphasis that i had early on or
the emphasis of that a lot of aikido
teachers had when they were young and
they were really excited about learning
aikido and they wanted to learn how to
fight and become a tough person and
through all their training they might
have learned to fight and become a tough
person but the martial art of aikido is
actually about making accords and the
more i gave to that the more aikido
seemed to make sense i started to
realize that aikido's first goal
is to be aware of what's going on and
mentally not allow a situation to form
that would be dangerous for us if that
situation forms anyways our next idea is
to keep distance from it and keep them
from getting too close to hurt us
if we can't manage keep distance well
then we want to suppress them and stay
off of the line
and if we can't do that well then there
is some struggle at the very end but
that's the last part of aikido and not
the ideal part of aikido now i
understand that this is something that
most people probably don't want to hear
and i don't expect that this video is
going to do too well because it isn't
about dominating and beating someone up
or having magic powers but it's about
realistically looking at the world we
live in and realizing the most
successful strategy you can possibly
have is to not get in fights at all so
if you can master not getting in fights
then that is the best strategy you can
have aikido can be a part of that and it
can help you learn that in fact even
though i didn't want it to be about that
it kind of taught me over time that that
is what it was about and i feel like the
most successful aikido comes from that
place now i've dedicated my life to
being an aikido teacher and becoming
really good at aikido and that includes
the whole spectrum of aikido right
including being able to struggle in
those situations and get out of it and
being able to move quick and being able
to use weapons and ideally also being
able to pay attention and not get into
conflict with those around you the whole
thing's important and we can't just
focus on one little bit so a lot of
times when people say oh aikido sucks
it's because they're looking at the
tiniest tiniest part of aikido overall
aikido is a really robust system that i
find is really good and if you're not in
a place in life where you're the biggest
strongest most capable person aikido
might be a really great martial art for
you to study
so i'm sorry if this might have been a
little bit of a letdown because we came
to realizing that aikido is really about
peaceful stuff and and good interactions
and i'm not saying that you shouldn't
learn to fight i think it's really good
to learn to fight i'm really pleased
with all the lessons i got from
different iterations of fighting but
you're not going to become a master of
fighting inside of aikido the system's
not built for that if you want to learn
to fight go outside of aikido if you
want to learn to stop fighting maybe you
should come into aikido
so i'm christopher hine thank you for
watching this three-part series i would
like to thank all of my patrons thank
you guys very much i couldn't do this
without you you guys help me buy
equipment take care of things if you're
interested in regular videos from me you
should check out my patreon page
christopher hine at patreon and i hope
to see you guys in videos in the future
thank you for watching
my